Lucifans can rejoice as everyone's favourite
devilish detective duo is back in the City
of Angels, and this time they've got demonic
prophecies and apple-loving ladies to deal
with.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and today
we're delving into the season 4 finale of
Lucifer on Netflix, how the ending relates
back to previous seasons, and what it all
means for the future of the show.
We will, of course, be talking spoilers, so
take care if you're not all caught up.
When Team Lucifer foil Father Kinley's end-of-the-world
prophecy and banish Dromos and his fellow
invading demons back to Hell in the season
4 finale, Chloe thinks it's over, but Lucifer
explains that now the demons know he doesn't
want to go back to the Underworld, they'll
eventually return to Earth, maybe putting
baby Charlie or Chloe in danger.
Luci breaks the news that he has to go and
be their king to contain them.
It's a bittersweet moment for Deckerstar fans
because Chloe then reveals that she loves
Lucifer and he confesses back to her:
"My first love was never Eve.
It was you, Chloe.
It always has been."
This is a huge moment for both characters,
especially Lucifer who not only sacrifices
the life he's built for himself in LA, but
also the chance to be with the person he truly
loves and who's grown to accept him for everything
he is.
In a selfless act, Lucifer gives it all up
and returns to Hell and, as he does, his white
feather angel wings return.
Lucifer had these last in the season 3 finale
when he used them to protect Chloe, but until
that moment in season 4, we've only seen him
with his much more devilish bat wings.
So, the return of Luci's angel wings show
that he's finally overcome his self-hatred
and angst over whether Chloe can accept him
for who he is and he's also finally come to
accept himself and stop battling his feelings
for the Detective.
And there's an interesting detail in this
scene which circles back to the penultimate
episode of season 3.
"Chloe, I am the devil.
No you're not.
Not to me."
In that scene, like this one, Lucifer also
called the detective by her real name "Chloe"
just before she kissed him.
Back then, obviously, Chloe thought Lucifer
was just referring to himself as the devil
metaphorically.
But after she discovered at the end of season
3 that Lucifer was quite literally the devil,
season 4 has been all about her coming to
terms with this knowledge.
Chloe's struggle to fully accept Lucifer's
demonic side causes her to fall out with Luci,
which sets up the introduction of Eve, someone
who already accepts Lucifer for who he is
and someone who's also similar to him as she
abandoned heaven because she was bored up
there in much the same way that Luci was bored
of Hell when he moved to LA.
Eve is madly in love with Luci, but her obsession
ends up being unhealthy for both of them.
When she encourages Lucifer to return to his
devilish, punishing ways, the difference between
her influence on him and Chloe's is summed
up perfectly in this scene where the three
of them go to confront Tiernan:
"Lucifer.
He will be punished.
Lucifer.
Lucifer, stop.
Lucifer, do it."
Eve is deliberately shown here as a devil-like
figure on Lucifer's shoulder goading him to
lean into his darker side while Chloe is the
opposite, an angel-like figure on his other
shoulder, reminding him that those things
are wrong.
Eve's portrayal during much of the season
is something of a reversal of her traditional
biblical story where she was tempted by a
serpent to take fruit from the Tree of Knowledge.
In the show, when Eve returns to Earth, she's
the one tempting the devil, whereas back in
the Garden of Eden, it was Luci doing the
tempting.
"Maybe you've read about it in a little book
called The Bible.
You know, the garden, the snake, the apple.
The metaphors were a bit off.
That's true.
The forbidden fruit was less of an apple and
more like a banana."
Because she was so wildly in love with Lucifer,
it seemed like she was going to be what set
Kinley's prophecy in motion and she did but
in a different way than perhaps expected as
she killed Kinley, sending a message to a
demon from Hell to come back in his body so
she and Lucifer could be together.
But eventually, by the end of the season,
Eve realises that she needs to truly discover
who she really is.
"I've realized the way I've been acting with
Lucifer is the exact same way I've acted with
Adam.
You know, I keep... trying to change myself
to... be this person I think they want me
to be.
I would never ask you to change, Eve.
I like who you are.
I don't even know who that is yet.
I need to figure that out.
I'm going to need to do that on my own."
It'll be interesting to see if Eve is brought
back into the show in a future season.
She admitted to Maze they had a connection
before she left, so they may still get together
in the future.
In the meantime, Kinley did mention to Eve
that she could be the Queen of Hell by Lucifer's
side and I wonder if there's a slight chance
that she might end up visiting him there,
even taking his place.
She did seem to love punishing evil-doers
on Earth so being in charge of that in Hell
could be a good fit, though perhaps she was
just doing that as she thought it was what
Luci wanted.
Ok, what other ways could Lucifer get out
of Hell in Season 5?
For a clue, let's revisit what happened at
the end of the first season.
In that season finale, Lucifer was killed
and went to Hell although it was only temporary
as he made a deal with his father, God.
An exact replay of that wouldn't be possible
this time as Lucifer needs a substitute ruler
to govern Hell in his place.
One possibility might be that Luci asks God
to send a different angel to keep control
over the Underworld.
Lucifer and Amenadiel have several siblings,
some of whom we've already met.
There's Remy who appeared this season when
she tried to take Amenadiel's baby back to
the Silver City.
And there's Azrael, aka the Angel of Death,
who was introduced in the Season 3 bonus episode
"Boo Normal".
In that episode, Azrael revealed that Lucifer
was one of her favourite brothers and that
she'd always meant to visit him in Hell after
his rebellion against God, and I wonder if
this time she'll make good on that and come
to see him in Season 5.
An alternative new character who could resolve
Lucifer's dilemma of being stuck in Hell is
Lilith, Adam's first wife.
She was namechecked a couple of times this
season, first by Eve:
"Lilith tamed the beasts of the night.
Stupid, perfect Lilith."
And then by Maze
"My mother, Lilith...
Let's just say she wasn't mom of the year."
Now, what's interesting is that Eve said that
"Lilith tamed the beasts of the night" suggesting
that if she were introduced to the show, she
could be a fearsome ruler who could keep Hell's
demons in check.
By the way, if you're a fan of Chilling Adventures
of Sabrina, this will make sense to you.
Something that could be an intriguing twist
is that rather than Lucifer going back to
LA, Chloe could instead become his queen in
Hell!
This isn't something I can see working easily
with all the other supporting characters who
would still be in LA.
So if it did happen, I could only see this
happening briefly until there was some other
resolution.
And talking of supporting characters, many
of them also went through crises like Lucifer,
Chloe and Eve this season.
Maze discovered she was becoming too dependent
on looking after Linda and her unborn child
after Linda told her she needed to find her
own partner.
Maze did make that connection with Eve, although
it wasn't reciprocated entirely, in a similar
way to how Lucifer was with about Eve.
So perhaps next season, we'll see Maze exploring
other potential partnerships as well as continuing
to kick ass.
The show's cast are all absolutely wonderful,
and Aimee Garcia is just perfect as Ella.
This season, Ella suffered a crisis of faith
after the death of Charlotte with both her
attitude and her T-shirts turning a little
darker.
And Ella and Dan also shared a brief intimate
moment which surprised me because it seemed
to come out of nowhere.
However, looking back over the season, it
seems they connected over their similar feelings
about the loss of Charlotte.
"Hope you know that I'm here for you.
You're not alone.
See, that's just it.
I never used to feel alone.
Because I always had the big guy.
I really miss him.
I was just so mad.
So mad after Charlotte.
I've been mad too."
But, by the end of the season, Ella puts her
crucifix back on and Dan understands the foolishness
of going back to his old shady ways.
As for Trixie, well, it was nice to see her
make up with Maze, but I wish we'd seen a
lot more of her as she's such a good actress
and her on-screen chemistry is so great with
all the adult actors.
"Where do you live?
Here.
Where are you from?
Far away.
I came here for Lucifer.
Keep the commentary to yourself, lady."
However, I think she may be a casualty of
having a shorter season now.
Fingers crossed, we see more of her next time.
By the way, if you're curious about what Maze
really said when she spoke Lilim to Linda,
tap at the top of the screen to check out
my other Lucifer video.
So, how do you feel about the ending to season
4 and do you have any predictions or things
you'd like to see in Season 5?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
Tap left to watch another Lucifer video with
devilish details about the show.
Or tap right for another video you're sure
to like.
And if you enjoyed this, a thumbs-up and a
share are hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!